لا يعرف هنا المواطنون منازلهم بالبت ولا
يعرفوا الطرقات التي تؤدي اليها تغيرت هنا
معالم المنطقه
بالكامل المنازل تداخلت على بعضها البعض
او ركام المنازل التي تداخل على بعضه
البعض هذه منطقه من المناطق المنكوبه ايضا
والله انا رايح على بيتنا مش عارف معالم
المنطقه مش عارف من وين بيتنا كان من وين
بدي ادخله مش عارف حجم الدمار لا يتصور
عقل هي اللي قدر عليه الاحتلال انه يدمرنا
والحمد لله على كل حال انسحبت هذه القوات
بالامس من هذه المنطقه وتمكن المواطنون من
العوده الى منازلهم لاول مره منذ بدء
العمليه البريه
هنا في منطقه ال 17 هذا مسجد عائشه في
منطقه لتوام ومنازل سويت بالارض بجواره
هنا المنطقه منكوبه تماما اه والله جينا
نفقد نشوف احوالنا نشوف دورنا ودور
قرايبنا يعني ما حدش يتوقع انه نلاقي
الدمار هيك هذه المنطقه ايضا اخفى
الاحتلال تضاريسها بالكامل هنا كان دوار
لتوام وهنا العديد من المنازل التي دالت
منها الاحزمه الناريه الكثيفه ح حيث دخلت
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى هذه المنطقه
منذ بدء العدوان البري كانت هي اوائل
المناطق التي شهدت اجتياحا للدبابات
الاسرائيليه وشهدت ايضا ضراوه جديده في
المقاومه هذه منطقه لتوام منطقه منكوبه
بالكامل فش شي
ضاير في مبرر لهذا الدمار اللي انت شايف
مبرر
ايش هذا دمار فيش
مبرر ايش بتتمنى مع بدايه العام انا عارف
بتمنى ايش الله يفك عنا ه
الضق انت بتحاول ايش تطلع والله ما طلعت
شي جيك ما طلعت شي احنا ايش دخلنا احنا
ناس مواطنين عاديين غلابه بتشتغل اصلا
بشتغل بتيجي بتلاقي الدمار وتلاقي الدار
رايحه شي ضايل ايش ضايل شي ضايل مش ضايل
شي يعني مش عارف ايش اقوللك ستر للاحتلال
كما تشاهدونها و وجد المواطنين رصاص الجيش
الاسرائيلي في هذه المنطقه وهنا العالم
يبدو ان هنا كان قد تعرضت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الى كمين كما تشاهدون في هذه
المنطقه هنا بواقي السترات العسكريه على
مقربه
هنا
تطلق قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الرصاص في
منطقه الامن العام وهذا ما يفسر ان
الانسحاب ليس
كاملا اشتباكات ضاريه في منطقه الامن
العام وهي منطقه قريبه من دوار لتوام قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يبدو انها لم تنسحب
من هذه المنطقه حتى اللحظه يا عمي وين
العالم وين الناس وين حقوق الانسان اللي
ولك قاعدين بسه بتموت في الشارع بسه الله
يعزك كلب كل اوروبا بتقوم عشانه احنا ناس
مدنيين ناس عرب مسلمين ما حدش ولا امه
عربيه ولا امه اسلاميه ولا
ولا ولا الهندوس بيعملوا هيك يا راجل
المجازر والدمار والموت والقتل حسبي الله
ونعم الوكيل ياتنا ان الحياه ترجع طبيعيه
زي ما كانت نرجع تتصلح هالدور والناس ترجع
على دورها ربنا يهدي البال يا شيخ احسن من
كل حال الله يزيل هالغمه وتخلص هالحرب
بدنا نرجع لبيوتنا ونشوف اهالينا اللي في
الجنوب حسبنا الله نعم
الوك